es una operación de rescate por mar y
aire que continúa a esta hora entre las
autoridades británicas y franceses y
algunos Pescadores que han acudido a la
zona de la tragedia para tratar de
ayudar la ministra del interior
sobremand confirmó hace pocos minutos en
el parlamento que cuatro personas han
muerto y 43 han sido rescatadas de Las
heladas aguas y de las bajísimas
temperaturas que azotan al Reino Unido
por varios días es ya la información
preliminar que se tiene es que al menos
50 personas habrían salido de la costa
francesa a bordo de una pequeña
embarcación no apta para este tipo de
viaje y muchísimo menos en estas
bajísimas condiciones este barco se
habría volcado en el mar en la madrugada
y por ello se Avanza en esta labor de
rescate Luisa podrá el gobierno frenar
la migración ilegal a través del Canal
de la Mancha tal y como se ha propuesto
en
el Primer Ministro Richi es una hizo esa
promesa hace apenas 24 horas por ello
presentó un plan que tiene cinco
elementos entre ellos más recursos más
personal trabajar de manera conjunta con
las autoridades de Albania por ejemplo
Porque esos ciudadanos dice el gobierno
no tendrán derecho pedir asilo en este
país porque es considerado una nación
segura así que serán devueltos
inmediatamente pero también incluye un
plan para luchar contra las bandas
delincuenciales que por altísimos cifras
transportan todos los días a personas a
este país en lo que va corrido de este
2022-45,000 personas han llegado a
través del Canal de la Mancha y esa
cifra puede seguir subiendo esta plan
del gobierno ha sido criticado por
inhumano y cruel y por qué no atacaría
el problema de fondo